HIROSHI LOCKHEIMER:
Apologies for the delay.
Thank you for coming.
Really appreciate it.
Obviously, a lot
of interest lately
on how Google's two computing
platforms, consumer computing
platforms, Chrome OS and
Android, could come together.
It's been a lot of speculation
on that and a lot of discussion
about that.
The approach we've
taken generally
is to take the best
attribute of each
and share it with the other.
So for instance,
yesterday at the keynote,
we talked about how
updates on Android
will use similar technology
to how Chrome OS updates work.
And today, we wanted to
talk about a technology
in the opposite direction
and give you a bunch of demos
and leave room,
hopefully, for Q&A. So I'm
going to be very brief
here and actually
introduce Kan, director of
product management for Chrome
OS, to update you on
our latest technology.
KAN LIU: Thanks, Hiroshi.
And good morning, everyone.
Most of us use our laptops
every day, and many of us
use them hours at a time.
We use our laptops
whenever we want
to be creative or
productive, whether it's
researching a family vacation,
or building the next killer
app, or just comparison
shopping to find a new laptop.
Having the speed of a keyboard,
the precision of a mouse
pointer, and the multitasking
capabilities of a large screen
can be extremely useful in
these kind of situations.
But for many years, laptops
and computers in general
were really hard to use.
They were slow,
and they got slower
the longer you used them.
They were insecure.
They were never up to date.
And worst of all, not everyone
could afford one, at least not
a good one.
So five years ago, we set
out to rethink the computer
and make computing a lot
more accessible for everyone.
This meant building an operating
system that was fast, secure,
and simple, but
most importantly,
focused on helping users get
their everyday stuff done.
And that's how
Chromebooks were born.
They're fast to start up,
easy to set up, simple to use,
and designed to be secure.
They're also always up to
date, and they get better
with every update.
Chromebooks are also incredibly
easy to manage and share,
and these attributes
and values have really
resonated with our users.
It has led to continued
momentum in Chromebooks.
In fact, today, all
the top computer makers
are building and
selling Chromebooks,
like Lenovo, Dell, HP,
Samsung, and many, many more.
In the education
market, Chromebooks
are now outselling all
other devices combined.
And we're also seeing strong
growth from enterprise,
where Chromebooks,
Chromebox for meetings,
and other purpose-built
Chrome devices
have been adopted
by large companies
like Whirlpool, Toyota,
Pinterest, and many more.
And of course, consumer demand
has been as strong as ever.
In fact, according to
IDC, in Q1 of this year,
Chromebook shipments
overtook Macs in the US.
[APPLAUSE]
So what that means is
thanks to your support,
Chrome OS is now the number
two most popular PC operating
system in the US.
We're incredibly humbled
and excited about this,
but this is really
just a reflection
of how well Chromebooks have fit
the needs and use cases of what
people are looking for.
So that's how things have
unfolded over the last five
years.
But in that time, the way
people use computing has also
changed a lot.
In particular, apps,
both iOS and Android,
have become a huge part of our
personal computing experience.
Whether it's checking the
weather app for your barbecue,
consuming the latest
snaps on Snapchat,
or just sending your favorite
track to your Sonos system,
apps have become a central
part of our everyday lives.
So we wanted to make
Chromebooks even better
by combining these experiences
and use cases with what people
already love about Chromebooks.
This means bringing together
the breadth and versatility
of the millions of
apps in the Play store
with the speed, simplicity,
and security of a Chromebook.
So that's why today,
we're announcing-- you
may have already heard--
we're bringing the Play
Store to Chromebooks.
[APPLAUSE]
So this means you'll
now be able to access
all your favorite Android
apps and games not
just on a phone or a tablet, but
also on a laptop running Chrome
OS.
So your Chromebook now
will have the world's
most popular and powerful
browser and the world's
most popular app store,
enabling multitasking
productivity apps like Adobe
Lightroom, Photoshop, Office,
Skype, plus all the
games you've already
come to love like "Clash
of Clans," "Hearthstone,"
"Need for Speed," and many
more, all on one device.
This also means you'll now have
access to apps and experiences
that you never had
access to on a PC
before, like
Snapchat, for example,
or our YouTube for Kids app.
So this means-- and I'm not
saying you should do this--
but you can actually
write your term paper
and get your snaps
all on the same device
without ever having to take
your phone out of your pocket.
So I'm here with
Katy Roberts Hoffman,
one of the product managers
on the Chromebook team,
and we're going to show
you how this all works.
All right, so let's switch
over now to the demo machine.
One of the first
things you'll notice
is this looks a lot like Chrome
OS, and that's because is it.
It's the same Chrome OS our
users have come to love.
It's fast.
It's simple.
It's secure.
But one of the big changes-- for
those of you with a sharp eye,
you may have already
noticed this.
There's now a Play Store icon
pinned to the bottom shelf.
So let's go ahead and open
up that icon, and here
you have the entire Play Store.
You'll be able to
browse through it
as you would on any
other Android device,
and you install any
app that you want.
In fact, let's try installing
this "Bejeweled Stars" app.
This looks like a
pretty fun-- for an app,
so let's go ahead and start
the installation process.
And there you go.
It's installing.
So now, while this
is installing,
one of the things I want
to talk to you about
is how seamlessly we've
integrated Android framework
into Chrome OS.
So things like-- for
example, she just showed you
the Notifications Center,
for Android notifications
will seamlessly open up in the
Notification Center as well.
So all of this is seamlessly
integrated together.
One of the things that I've
been meaning to do recently
that my wife keeps
reminding me about
is building a poster for my
daughter's third birthday.
And so I'm going to take an
example here and actually show
you how I'm going to do
this on a Chromebook now.
So to give you a little
background, my daughter's
favorite activities and
favorite things in the world
are-- one is Piglet,
and two is ice cream.
Unfortunately, I don't actually
have a photo of my daughter
with both Piglet and ice cream,
so I need to create one first.
Wouldn't it be great if I could
Photoshop a photo like that?
So I've actually got Photoshop
Mix already installed
on this device from
the Play Store,
so I'm going to open that up.
And here, I've already got
loaded a photo of my daughter
with Piglet from
our last vacation.
She's actually trying to
feed Piglet a pen right now.
Let's see if we can add a
photo of ice cream instead.
So let's go ahead and
click the Plus button.
It turns out Adobe Stock
has some great photos in it.
And in fact, they've got
a really one of Neapolitan
ice cream cone--
which, by the way,
is a really great dessert
that starts with the letter N,
in case anybody's looking
for something to vote.
So it's a little
out of proportion.
That's OK.
So she has a touch
screen here, so she's
going to use her fingers
to actually rotate and put
the ice cream cone and resize
it to just the right place.
So this looks pretty
good, but this still
doesn't look quite right because
the ice cream cone is actually
sitting on top of her hand.
So let's go ahead
and cut out the part
of the cone that's
overlapping so it
looks more like she's holding
It.
So go ahead and zoom in.
Again, she's using her hand
here to manipulate directly,
and it's just really
easy with her finger just
to cut out exactly the
portion of the photo that's
overlapping.
So we've done this with
multiple layers with her hand.
It's just really
easy on a Chromebook.
And now all of a sudden,
we've got a great image.
But I'm going to save this
now so I can import this
into the poster I'm
actually working on in Word.
So let's go ahead and save it.
It's saved.
Let's go ahead and
close that out.
Now, switch over
to Office, where
I've already got
the poster loaded,
but it's missing the photo.
So let's go ahead and
click Insert Pictures,
and let's select the photo
that we just created.
And there you go.
I think that looks pretty good.
So now I'm going to go ahead
and share this with my wife,
and it's pretty easy
on a Chromebook now.
All you have to do is
click the Share button,
send as an attachment,
file type, Gmail.
And just like that, the
Gmail app automatically
pops up with a document
already attached,
and all I have to do is type the
email address, and it's sent.
And that's because of the
way that we've seamlessly
integrated the Android
intents system into Chrome OS,
so it's the exact same
experience you already
have on your phone, simple
flow that you already
have on your phone or a tablet.
So another really compelling and
great feature of Android apps
is that they work
really well offline.
For example, if you're on
an airplane without Wi-Fi,
you can still edit your photos.
You can still play your
favorite playlists.
You can still type up a
document or watch a Play movie.
All that stuff just
works seamlessly
on Android devices
and Android apps.
So here we've got another
demo machine set up,
and if you look at
the right corner here,
you'll see that it's completely
disconnected, completely
without Wi-Fi.
And I'm going to go
ahead and show you
another one of my
favorite games, which
is "Galaxy On Fire 2."
So this app is awesome.
It's super smooth from
a graphics perspective.
It allows her to actually
use the touchscreen controls
to go ahead and fly around.
And because it's
on a laptop, it's
using the desktop
class hardware as well.
So this experience is
actually pretty great.
Maybe one of the
things we can do
is actually switch over
to the Play Movies app
so I can show you how I
can watch a real movie.
So I've got the Play
Movies app open here.
And again, because we're
completely offline,
apps like Play Movies just work.
And this is showing
me all the movies
that I've already downloaded.
It turns out I'm a big
"Kung Fu Panda" fan,
but I actually haven't had
time with everything going on
to catch up on the
latest "Kung Fu Panda 3."
So why don't we go ahead
and click "Kung Fu Panda 3"
and play it and click play?
And there it goes.
I can now watch my movie
completely offline without ever
having any internet connection.
So this isn't obviously
just true for Play Movies,
but it's also true for things
like your Play Music, your Play
Books.
For Google Photos, which happens
to be a really great app,
that works completely offline.
So you can sync all your
photos and be able to view them
on an airplane.
And now all these
apps and experiences
work completely offline
on a Chromebook as well.
So thanks, Katy.
And that was just
a small glimpse
of some of the cool
new things you'll
be able to do on a Chromebook.
And we're super excited about
this, but since this is I/O,
let's geek out for a moment
and actually tell you
guys about how we did this.
So we've been working
very closely and side
by side with the Android
team to make both Chromebooks
and Android better.
For example, as Hiroshi
mentioned earlier,
we've actually brought
the Chrome OS A/B update
system to Android N.
While we were doing
this, we realized
that we can use the Linux
container, which is actually
a really popular technology
that's used in data centers
around the world and Google
actually uses in our own cloud
infrastructure today, to
bring Android framework on top
of the existing Chrome OS stack.
So this allows us
to bring together
the best of both worlds.
For example, in addition to
Android security features
like SC Linux,
the container also
provides a secure and
isolated runtime environment,
and all of this is built on
top of the security foundations
of existing Chrome OS, such
as verified boot, user data
encryption, continuous
updates every six weeks.
And this isn't just
for the Chrome OS side,
but also for the Android
framework as well.
So that means all
these apps will
be running on the latest
stack with the latest security
patches and the latest APIs.
And this container is
actually integrated completely
with the Chrome OS system
services like input/output,
graphics, connectivity.
We've basically built an Android
hardware abstraction layer,
and we've put the Android
framework on top of it.
This enables us to run the full
Android framework natively,
and that's how we can
ensure Android apps can
run full speed with no overhead
and no performance penalties
from emulation or
virtual machines.
This also means that
Chromebooks are now
fully compatible
with any Android app.
Of course, like all
Android devices,
regardless of whether it's a
phone, tablet, or a laptop,
the Google Play Store will
allow installation of apps
based on the hardware
components on these devices.
So for example, a
phone dialer app
may require cellular
capabilities
in order to install.
So with Play Store
coming to Chromebooks,
we've been working
with our partners
to ship more and more devices
that will have the hardware
components to support more
of these use cases and apps
that users want to install
on their computers.
And because of the
increased value
that users are now
getting, our partners
are also shipping
more premium devices,
like some of these from
Dell, HP, and Lenovo
that have already
come out recently.
And finally, the Play
Store and Android apps
will work regardless of the
SLC platform on the device.
This means it'll support
both ARM and Intel platforms.
In fact, today's demos
were run both on a ARM
device and an Intel device.
So next, I'm actually
going to bring up
my friend and colleague,
Rajen, who leads the Chrome OS
and Android education
and enterprise
teams to give you a
little bit more insight
and talk about the
implications of having the Play
Store on Chromebooks for both
enterprise and education.
[APPLAUSE]
RAJEN SHETH: Thank you, Kan.
And with enterprise
and education,
we talked a little bit about
how Chromebooks have been
a great success in education.
But really, to take a step
back, the reason for this
is that there are two
big trends happening
in enterprise and education.
The first is more and more
companies and schools are
moving to the cloud.
What seemed kind of
heretical 10 years ago
is actually now
becoming mainstream.
And so we see the
Chromebook as a great way
for businesses and schools
to take advantage of that.
But the other big thing is
that businesses and schools
want to bring computing
to more of their users,
more of their employees,
more of their students,
and actually transform their
organizations by doing so.
So we've seen this
in schools first.
That's the first place
that this has happened.
So as an example, we have
about 50 million students
that are using Google Apps for
Education on an active basis,
and there are many other
cloud-based applications,
things like Khan Academy,
things like Brain Pop that
are being used throughout
schools to really transform
education.
But the thing that schools told
us about five years ago was
this is all great,
but it's not great.
It doesn't let us
change our curriculum
unless we're able
to get computing out
to more of our students
on a daily basis.
Chromebooks fit that
need extremely well.
They were easy to use, easy
to manage, easy to share,
and also very affordable.
And so schools really gravitated
to Chromebooks as the way
that they could bring productive
tools to their students
and actually change
how they teach.
As Kan mentioned,
last year, a majority
of the devices that went out
into schools in the United
States were Chromebooks.
But more importantly,
it's actually
changed how those schools teach.
Schools can actually
move more towards
individualized education and
blended learning, concepts
that actually make it so
that students learn better.
And that's the thing
that we're most proud of.
We're now seeing that same
trend happen in business.
Over 2 million businesses are
using Google Apps for Work.
But in addition
to that, there are
many other cloud-based
applications
that businesses
are migrating to,
and so the Chromebook
again is a perfect fit
for that kind of environment.
But also, what we're also
hearing from our customers
is that there are many
employees that they want
to give access of computing to.
As an example, there
are 3.2 billion people
walking into a workplace
in the world today.
However, there are only about
750 million PCs in businesses
today.
So there are many,
many users that
don't have any
access to computing,
and we want to change that.
We've already seen this happen
with Chromebooks-- for example,
in retail stores, where they're
enabling all of their employees
to have access to computing
and changing their processes as
well.
We've seen this happen in places
like hotels and restaurants
and manufacturing
plants as well.
We've invested very
heavily over the course
of the last couple of years
to really make Chromebooks
fit well in the enterprise.
We've invested in making
sure that we integrate
with enterprise
infrastructure so it really
fits in well with what
businesses have today.
We've also worked
with our partners
like HP, Lenovo,
Dell, Acer, and Asus
to have enterprise-specific
Chromebooks that really meet
the needs of business users.
But the one big thing
that was still missing
is app compatibility.
Can I do the kinds
of things that I
need to do on this device?
And this is where
we think having
Android apps on the Chromebook
will be transformational.
Now businesses can use
all of the key apps
that they typically
use, whether it's
things like QuickBooks,
or Office, or Skype,
or many, many
others that are now
available in the Play Store.
But in addition to that,
they can use them offline.
Students can start to use
a lot of the learning tools
that are available on
Android and actually
bring touch-based applications
to students, for example,
in lower grades.
And so we think that this can
actually transform, really,
how businesses approach
computing once again.
So with that, I'll
bring Kan back on
to round up our session.
[APPLAUSE]
KAN LIU: Hey.
Thanks, Rajen.
So we think all of this is
really great for our users,
but we also believe this
is going to be really
great for developers too.
If your app runs on an
Android device today,
it will now be able to
run on a Chromebook too.
So with the same Android
framework and platform
you're used to, you'll be
able to bring your existing
apps to a whole new category
of devices and form factors,
and that opens up all
kinds of new possibilities.
As a developer, you can
now create new experiences
for track pads,
keyboards, larger
screens, multiple windows.
It also means new
business models.
Desktop software
can oftentimes be
priced in the
hundreds of dollars
or even thousands of
dollars, and that's
because we can be more
productive and more creative
on our laptops.
We can create a movie.
We can design a whole house,
or we can write our PhD thesis.
So when is all this actually
coming to Chromebooks?
Google Play will start rolling
out in the next Chrome Dev
Channel, M53.
It'll be available
on select devices
first, with many more
devices to follow soon after.
We hope this will be a
great way for developers
to start testing their
existing apps on Chromebooks
and even start creating new
experiences for this form
factor so that they'll be ready
when we start rolling this out
to users later this year
along with new hardware that
has been designed with
the Play Store in mind.
So as we've always
said, Chromebooks
have always been
about making computing
more accessible for everyone.
And by bringing together the
best of Android and Chrome OS,
we believe we're making
a big leap forward
because not only are we
addressing many of the use
cases and needs that people have
with their Chromebooks today,
but we're also betting on the
millions of Android developers
that are out there
innovating every day
to create new experiences and
experiences that have never
even been possible on
a PC platform before.
So this is just the
beginning, and we're
super excited to see what the
future holds for everyone.
So thank you all for
coming, and now I'm
going to actually bring up
a few members of the team
and open it up to
press Q&A. Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]